Costa Rica's rainforest is home to a
rich variety of flora and fauna
over 1/4 of the country's territory is
protected as Conservation Area the human
forest is an ideal climate for
biodiversity survivors for me but of
Abhi's here and I go to the rain forest
to get away from it all
but breathe fresh air explore and find
peace what's special about the forest is
this diversity that grows and fades
together and is constantly creating new
life entrepreneur lay oppressed flesh
shuttles back and forth between Costa
Rica and Germany he's found a way to
combine business and environmental
protection
by the 1980s over three quarters of
Costa Rica's rainforest had been cleared
to make way for single crop agriculture
he has in the ananda the pineapple has
spread out like an octopus here and
taken over the whole area the pineapple
plants have to be sprayed and they leach
the soil so it can't be used for
anything else the runoff trickles into
the rivers and kills off the fish but
who foots the bill for that exhibit site
the second legal layup wrestler and his
son Stefan have launched a reforestation
project that protects biodiversity the
almond tree for example sustains rare
species of macaws in 2007 Stefan Costa
settled in Costa Rica and now manages
the project on site when I started out I
was only interested in planting new
forests meanwhile we've started working
under the three pillar model of social
ecological and economic returns of
working towards a system of production
that really is sustainable income
funding from German investors is going
towards planting mixed forests here the
first actual returns take 24 years to
materialize when the trees are harvested
they've planted nearly 30 species of
tree many native and precious woods
where the trees grow too thick a few of
them are felled ahead of time the
project doesn't just create revenue but
jobs as well
once a week Stefan pressed limits with
his team at home to discuss new plans
among the hardest part of my job is
actually the intercultural side we come
here from Germany and talk about how
important it is to protect the
rainforest and its biodiversity while
back in Germany we cut down all the
forests and replanted them centuries ago
and what we in Germany see as a treasure
is quite often not valued as much here
if unity of the nice will be shed the
local population is more accepting of
the project when there's something in it
for them the small tree farms double as
vegetable patches in the shade farmers
grow ginger for export to Germany
ginger benefits both the workers and the
trees themselves for the advantage of
this agroforestry is that it results in
a good homogeneous soil profile which
helps the trees to grow better the goal
is for the locals to eventually make a
living from the project
people have returned to an abandoned
finca or plantation as well as tree
farming they make cheese and produce
fertilizer from cow dung
penny IBS has been involved in the
forest project for two years now firstly
because I like it I like working with
plants I don't know much about it but I
learned on the job and I'm interested in
working with plants it takes decades for
the little seedlings to grow into mighty
trees at present the project employs
about a hundred workers so far investors
in Germany have put a good 30 million
euros into this very long-term project
I mean what kind of hunters I'm not so
worried about it being a long-term
project it all goes with a whole
attitude to life and I have my
experience from my first year here I was
always so worried about the little
seedlings you could hardly see them in
the tall grass and today they've grown
into a real forest that gives you a
lasting sense of fulfillment
well annotate him Stefan Prospero has
left his old life as an event technician
far behind him he started a family in
Costa Rica and taught himself the
complexities of reforestation it's one
of the most important aspects of a
project like this is taking
responsibility for what you do that's
one difference to other projects that
are directed by a hired manager they
know they'll be at it for five or at
most ten years but not for thirty or
forty or fifty years but to whom this
responsibility down through generations
is one of the strengths of this project
everyone is there for everyone else and
they know they have to do it right
vice versa is a stigma
Leo Posner is planning to move back to
Germany leaving the project in the
long-term care of his son by the time
the first trees are harvested and the
investors see their returns Stefan
prosto will be almost as old as his
father is now
you